What are the suggested cutters, protocols for peripheral neuropathy?
Well, there are both. So really, depending on what the cause of the peripheral neuropathy is.
So it's finished a question. I visited a clinic that works with neuropathy patients and their protocols use the rebuilder.
This is, is this a newer model than the one you sell? So the rebuilder 20407 is a, is a rebuilder 300 plus an EMS machine piece to a two that is far more expensive.
You don't need the EMS piece to the machine. So we don't sell this one specifically for that purpose. You don't need that higher, there's no need for that higher cost piece.
If you have neuropathy, so we only sell the rebuilder 300. That's fine. We sell them.
Secondly, light therapy for angiogenesis.
So I think they're giving you a little bit where light therapy, they may be doing laser therapy.
And they're calling it light therapy. So it might be laser therapy. I would ask them if it what what class laser they have. So lasers come in a class one, two, three, four, four.
There's also lasers that are called three B lasers.
I would find out what class laser that they're using.
Laser for peripheral neuropathy can help too. So that's enough. That is a good therapy. But if they're using a class one laser or even a class two laser.
And you know, you have to use a lot of time with a laser like that to really see any change with their opportunity. You really have to go to a three B or a four laser. So I would ask them what class laser.
Benevolent management. What would you suggest? Well, the biggest thing for neuropathy is vitamin B6.
But again, you're also dealing with what type of neuropathy. So person has peripheral neuropathy due to diabetes. It's a totally different metabolic management that peripheral neuropathy due to chemotherapy.
You want to help detoxifying through your feed too. So using your eye and pro wave would be another thing. So I would agree with using rebuilder rebuilder stimulates at the frequency electrical frequency of the nerve itself to help regrow their pathways.
I would agree, well, hardly with laser therapy, especially if it's a class three B or four.
Benevolent management for peripheral neuropathy in general, no matter what cause would be B6.
And then secondly, if the class is if the cause is a.
From chemotherapy induced peripheral neuropathy that you have to look at detoxification and we already have you are things for your detoxification pathways. So there's no things to add for that.
I would definitely add that I am pro wave. How long would you guess the right programs for neuropathy take for someone with neuropathy for three months and as approximately 30% neuropathy to the feet.
So it depends on a couple factors. So if there's no more assault or no more causation.
So in this case, chemotherapy induced neuropathy and you stopped doing chemotherapy and you're not doing any more chemotherapy.
Still, you have damage to the nerves that have to heal. And it hurts heal very slowly. So you're going to look at multiple months before you're going to see changes, plus it depends on how bad the neuropathy is.
So neuropathy is damaged to the peripheral nerves and you damage the type of nerves that you damage first or the call them large diameter, a parent nerves, those are the nerves that carry centering back to the brain.
You have small diameter and large diameter a parents and those large diameter efforts that are damaged first with chemotherapy and with diabetic neuropathy.
So you'll have the same symptoms with either one of these types of neuropathy and it's going to be tingling in your feet and then you'll get numbness in your feet and you won't feel your feet finally.
So, so it depends on how long, how far you've progressed on that path. So if you have numbness in your feet or you don't feel your feet, the next thing you're going to feel as those nerves come back to life is pain and is tingling. So you're going to go through that what you went through getting to the point of numbness.
You're going to go through that again. So your symptoms when you start working on your neuropathy, your symptoms of neuropathy could actually worsen before they get better because you're waking up to nerves and helping them regal low again and you're, and these are a parent pathways a parent pathways means they're carrying sensory information back back to the brain.
The parent pathways are carried information from the brain to the tissue, in case this case, there would be motor pathways, but the a parent pathways that are damaged have to regrow again and when they wake up, you're going to feel more pain.
So you may get feel like you're getting worse before you get better and it takes time. How long is it going to take you get better? If you're still doing chemotherapy, well, it's just you're just battling, you know, it's, it's, it's an endless town because you're causing more damage every time you do the chemotherapy.
So I would say, you know, that you're doing high-end pro waves daily, and that's why I'm big into you having a rebuilder at home so that you can do it, you know, twice a day.
It's hard to have a laser at home because they're pretty pricey, but you can certainly have a rebuilder 300 at home, I don't know about 800 bucks.
And you already have the early pro, so you can do most of this work at home. If you're going into a clinic and doing it three times a week, you're going to have much more limited success. So that would be my suggestion.